اذا ماذا تحتاج ايران وهي تقترب اكثر من
اي وقت من السلاح النووي الكثير
وفقا لاحدث التقارير تمتلك ايران الان 75
كغم من اليورانيوم بنسبه 60% لكنها من اجل
صناعه سلاح النووي تحتاج الى اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسبه 90% اذا ما يزال امام ايران
بعض الوقت كي تنجح في مساحها لكن لا يمكن
للغرب الاعتماد على هذا الامر لان اجهزه
التخصيب لديها تعمل باقصى سرعه وطهران
تحدثها باستمرار والان يلوح خطر المساعده
الروسيه
لنفترض ان ايران وصلت للقنبله الثابت لدى
الخبراء ان هذه القنبله ستكون بدائيه
مقارنه بما هو موجود في عالم اليوم ستكون
مثل القنبله هيروشيما وافضل طريقه
لاستخدامها ستكون عبر اسقاطها جوا وهذا
بالنسبه للاهداف القريبه امام بالنسبه
لضرب من بعيده فالامر اكثر صعوبه يجب على
ايران حينها تصميم قنبله بمواصفات خاصه
لوضعها على راس صاروخ مع مراعاه مشكلات
تقنيه معقده للصاروخ الذي سيحملها ومنها
الخروج من الغلاف الجوي والعوده للهدف اذا
متى يمكن ان تصل ايران لهذه النقطه المده
التي قد تحتاجها لصنع سلاح تدور في اطار
العامين لكن هناك شيئا شديد الاهميه لفتى
اليه ايضا جروس سابقا ما تكتسبه ايران من
خبره ما يمكن عكسه وهنا ايضا روسيا يمكن
ان تساعد في القفصه النوويه المعرفيه
لايران واعتماد ربما على مدى احباط بوتن
او غضبه من دعمته
[موسيقى]